[Música]
soy corina mi hijo tiene tea y lo amo
hola soy lupita mi hijo tiene una lesión
cerebral severa y profunda también lo
vamos y él se recabaron enrique es un
niño feliz amoroso y lleno de luz quien
lo conoce lo ama y es el motor de
nuestras vidas cuando supimos que
seríamos padres nuestras vidas se
llenaron de planes y de ilusiones cuando
él nació queríamos que tuviera lo mejor
su desarrollo fue feliz y normal excepto
que a sus casi tres años él no hablaba
como otros niños de su edad también le
temía a muchos sonidos y tenía
movimientos repetitivos que uno como
madre sabe que no es normal
sabíamos que enrique tenía algo pero no
sabíamos que era exactamente
yo conocía en ese entonces a un niño con
autismo y veía muchas cosas de ese niño
en enrique
pero menos intensidad así que decía
enrique tiene lo de josé luís pero no es
lo de josé luís
lo que es no saber que cada niño dentro
del espectro es diferente que si conoces
a un niño con autismo solamente conoces
a ese niño con autismo cada uno es único
enrique tiene sus emociones tan fuertes
que brinca aletea sus manitas y abre su
boquita es tan intenso que incluso se
llega a trabajar eso nos asustaba al
principio pero después de tantas vueltas
citas y estudio en el lynx la
neuropediatra nos confirmó que era
trastorno de espectro autista
en ese momento nuestros planes de
ilusiones se derrumbaron se cayeron en
pedazos
y andy es un niño que tiene un carácter
muy fuerte va a paralelo a su condición
estoy invitar en este momento a pensar
en aquel niño mocetón de primaria al que
ahora le llamamos bullying
tienen a alguien en sus mentes
si no tienen a nadie en su cabeza
aseguraron ustedes los de cabrones así
el filial cuando él entró primero de
primaria conocí a tamara una de sus
mejores amigas y de sus personas
favoritas a tamara le jalaba el cabello
esposada en la tableta y se la giraba
para que no hubiera lo que le gustaba
hasta llegó a ser la tijera en el cuello
con el piel cuando tomás lloraba y él se
carcajeaba muy sabroso cualquiera
pensaría que se burlaba
un día estamos en el centro histórico de
guadalajara comiendo y arremetió el pie
a un mesero el joven tropezó y casi cayó
con su charola
se regresó inmediatamente ofrecernos
disculpas pero la cara de ian fue de
indiferencia fue una grosería a penas y
sima de la situación que mi hijo había
provocado ofrecí disculpas al joven y
éste se retiró
el re cabrón de ian seguro
a veces uno de mis reguladores para
lidiar con la discapacidad es pensar de
una manera jocosa en ella cuando y anda
la nota en público pienso que por esa
razón antes negaban y escondían a los
hijos con discapacidad en mexico no
llevamos más de dos décadas que se habla
con menos pena de esto
de hecho quienes tenemos un hijo con
discapacidad en la calle frecuentemente
escuchamos que mala madre eres no
desempeña su bien tu trabajo qué
maleducado tienes a tu hijo déjamelo a
mí y verás
tú utilizas el autismo como excusa tú
sobre proteger a tu hijo no lo enfrentas
a sus miedos
tú eres la que quiere que tenga autismo
sólo es berrinchudo
sólo es berrinchudo seguro yo quiero que
tenga autismo si yo soy la que quiero
que tenga autismo
yo quiero gastar el dinero que no tengo
en terapias costosas llevar y traer a
enrique no estar en mi casa y no poder
trabajar claro que mejor tenga autismo
verdad
a mí me encanta cuando me dicen en la
calle son una bendición
la verdad es que yo me imagino nadie en
sus oraciones de la noche diciendo y
cuando despierte que tengo un hijo que
convulsiona en casa tampoco imagino
matrimonio a la dulce espera que diga y
que tengamos un hijo down o sordo o
ciego no sé si me explico una bendición
se pide un hijo con discapacidad es un
hijo más con todo lo que implica
les voy a tratar de explicar que steam
tea es un trastorno neurobiológico del
desarrollo y se vive toda la vida con él
ahora les voy a decir que no es no es
una enfermedad porque no se cura no es
una tragedia pero la ignorancia así
los niños con autismo son extremadamente
literales en su mayoría enrique me lo
diagnosticaron a los 3 casi cumple 6 y
yo no aprendo a ser literal enrique le
encanta el agua es característico de los
niños con autismo y el des no es la
excepción un día que estaba bañándose en
su alberca vi que la bandeja del agua
del gato estaba a la mitad y le dije
enrique échale agua al gato imaginen
nada más la escena el muy obediente
agarro la manguera voltio a todos lados
y corrió a echarle agua al gato
yo toda histérica gritando no bebe al
gato no sale agua échale agua y volteaba
a verme
si vuelve a correr detrás del gato
hacerle agua hasta que caiga en cuenta
que le tenía que decir mi amor échale
agua a la bandeja del gato
cuando bien cumplió un año la ciencia me
dijo que ya no tenía nada que ofrecerme
pero que cada cinco años podrían salir
estudios nuevos que me ayudarán a saber
cómo tratarlo
en ese momento de choque mi mente tuvo
la claridad de decidir ser feliz con
ella y con mi hijo mayor
nada ha sido fácil mi familia lleva 11
años viviendo y conviviendo con la
discapacidad no creo que algo sea fácil
después
entendí que el primer regalo el primer
cumpleaños de ella sería mi amor mi
tiempo y paciencia
y entiende cuadriplejia espástica de
historia al convulsivo de causa
biológica desconocida
él tiene una personalidad y un carácter
que van paralelos a su condición hemos
identificado que su área cognitiva es
mucho más avanzada que su condición
física partiendo de esto hermano tíos
primos abuelos y amigos logran encontrar
en ella ese niño travieso que es logran
detectar el liderazgo que impone y
ocasionalmente logran blindarse de su
ternura
pero esto es lo bonito corina que te
duele de la discapacidad
me duele no saber si estoy haciendo lo
correcto
me duele no saber que no estaré para él
para siempre y no saber cómo lo trataran
la indiferencia de una sociedad gobierno
incluso de familias y amigos
me duele que de las escuelas me lo
rechacen porque el maestro no quiere
salir de su área de confort
el sector salud que lo quiere tratar
como esquizofrénico
las del bullying por parte de sus
compañeros las miradas que juzgan y
rechazan a mi hijo
eso es lo que más duele
y a ti y lupita que te duele de la
discapacidad
me duele reconocer en la mirada de otras
madres el temor a lo desconocido a no
saber qué sigue ni cómo lo lograrás
que no importa cuánto hagas o cuánto
renuncies no será suficiente
me duele me aterra la broncoaspiración
tamara la mejor amiga de ella tiene
apenas un mes que no resistió y ya no
está
su madre una mujer valiente sus hermanas
son las niñas que se quedan llenas del
amor que crearon para tamara hoy les
pido un aplauso para ellas
saben que están un poco mi dolor
identificar a los hermanos de niños con
discapacidad qué manera de madurar
se vuelven tan sensibles a tan corta
edad desarrollan un caparazón y la
coraza de protección y una garra para
sobrevivir increíble
nuestras vidas de un giro de 180 grados
después de tanto llorar de tantas
terapias de tanto leer nos dimos cuenta
que aquellas ilusiones y planes que se
derrumbaron solamente fue el simple
hecho de no saber nada de la condición a
leer te das cuenta que aquellas
ilusiones pueden seguir porque tu hijo
puede salir adelante trabajando
organizando te llevándolos a terapias el
autismo nos abrió los ojos a otro mundo
que estaba ahí y no veíamos
con el autismo aprendes a disfrutar cada
segundo cada triunfo por más pequeño que
sea y cada detalle como si fuera lo más
grandioso del mundo
hace poco de más de un año la asociación
la casa de los ángeles en la tierra tuvo
su primera jornada de autismo aquí en
ciudad obregón asistimos y desde
entonces he asistido a cada plática y
cada conferencia que ha dado aprendo y
me he dado cuenta cuánto ha avanzado
enrique
cuando yo leí agrando man en su libro
que hacer por su hijo con lesión
cerebral aprendí cómo tratar a ella
el doctor román en su investigación
asegura que las familias de clase
adinerada construían trajes de metal
armaduras de acero para ayudar a los
hijos a mantenerse de pie cuando las
retiraban ni su cuerpo ni su mente
mostraban avances
por otro lado en la investigación llegó
a las familias de clase baja de escasos
recursos las que le decían yo amarró a
mi hijo en la silla del comedor para que
coma con nosotros y cuando terminó lo
tiró al piso para hacer mis quehaceres
en esos niños se observó una mayor
integración social se observó que
lograban integrar por lo menos el
arrastre es la primera etapa de
movilidad de todo ser humano y la
expectativa de vida era más grande
en ese momento entendí que el lugar más
seguro para ella era el piso no es que
lo ame menos desde entonces está
apoderada de la sala de mi casa yo no
uso mesa del centro
aprendí algo muy importante
que la ciencia en el tema cerebro tiene
mucho por descubrir
eso amplio misma nora más despresurizó
mis pensamientos para lidiar con la
discapacidad en mi hogar
algo que aprendí estoy completamente
segura de ello es que el autismo no se
cura pero se puede sobrellevar
se puede sobrellevar
lo que quiero decir es que el 90% del
trabajo es de los papás y el 10% es de
los profesionales
los terapeutas no son dios
con una hora a la semana el trabajo no
hacen milagros sin embargo ellos son las
herramientas que debemos de utilizar los
padres para ayudar a nuestros hijos
ellos tienen el conocimiento y nosotros
lo aplicaremos para sacarlos adelante
con tiempo de calidad porque estar todo
el día con ellos no quiere decir que
avanzarán sin embargo pueden estar tres
horas y ver grandes avances
el autismo para poderlo sobrellevar es
el trabajo la constancia la organización
el amor y sobre todo mucha pero mucha
paciencia papás no se dejen llevar por
curas milagrosas no existen no expongan
a sus hijos no se dejen engañar por
charlatanes que solamente están jugando
con su dolor y quieren su dinero
trabajen duro acerquen sana
organizaciones y a otros padres verán
que no están solos y juntos nos vamos a
ayudar
yo decidí vivir y convivir del lado de
la discapacidad acepté mi situación la
de mi familia eso me liberó hizo ligera
mismo chila
hasta te los días como son
no permito que utilicen cerca de
nosotros la palabra lástima en casa a
nadie es indefenso y ya no ocupa más
ayuda que cualquier otro niño pero no es
indefenso
hago chistes de la discapacidad en carta
le hacemos bullying ahí es más le
tenemos un eslogan familiar y en
escuadra méxico no prende
tiene mis días de fe y estoy lista para
vivir el plan de dios yo hago en la
tierra lo que me toca
el autismo es constancia y trabajo arte
es un estilo de vida que vale la pena
por nuestros niños
vivir y convivir con la discapacidad es
cuestión de actitud de valorar la vida
el respirar el parpadear y vencer
cansancio
[Aplausos]